Beim Rettungsschirm verwenden wir schlussendlich ganz einfach die einzelnen Meistens Autonema,
wo er dick sind und auch viel weniger dicht gewoppen sind.
Wie geht der, ist das Wichtige vor der Schuhe angesprochen, dass wenn man ein Öffnung hättet,
dass es nicht riesige Belastung gibt, sondern das ganze System, das Däne ist absolut
säckend, dass das Formstabil, Längestabil ist, das Döffsichtäne, Sätze, Däne,
hat eigentlich die positiven Eigenschaften.
Beim Rettungsschirm gibt es ganz verschiedene Modell, da gesehen wir schnell momentan, da es in der Mitte
ist so genannte Kreuzkappen, das ist so ein bisschen das, was aktuell vom Markt ist und sehr gut funktioniert.
Den links unten, die rot ist eher älteres Modell, das ist eine Rundkappen,
wo man danklich verdrängt wird von der Kreuzkappen aus einem einfachen Grund,
weil die Kreuzkappen sehr pendelstabil ist und bei der Rundkappen haben wir ehrenmal ein Pendeln innen Commissionen.
Und da gibt es auch noch verschiedene andere Formen, das ist jetzt noch so ein Dreieck,
wo man gleich an Fahrt aufnehmen kann und mit dem kann stören, dass alle Dinge mehr für Profis vorbehalten,
weil man doch nach dem Drehbezug auch nochmals aktiv den Rettungsschirm stören.
Für einen Schieler, für jemanden, der abanken, macht das Absatz in den Kreuzkappen mit dieser Kunstabend.
Und alles ist gut und du musst die nicht nach irgendwelchen Verrettungssystem konzentrieren.
Wenn man einen Rettungsschirm, einen Rettungsschirm gratuziert,
dann kommt man ungefähr mit 5,5 Meter pro Sekunden, aber das entsp
das entspricht ungefähr, wie man hier auf dem Bild gesehen hat, von der Höhe von 1,5 Meter.
Jetzt haben wir aber bei 1,5 Meter Sprung nichts nichts an,
sondern wir haben die ganze Gleichschirm aus der Üstungsgurz,
unsere Kleiderhelme z. a.
Das heißt, das ist schnell noch viel Gewicht.
Und dann sind die 1,5 Meter plötzlich eher schwierig.
Oder auch doch mit einer kleinen Impact an dem Boden verbunden, wenn man so abspringt.
In der Realität sieht es nämlich so aus, dass man eher von 2,3 Meter abspringen will.
Die Rettungsschirm werden testet, in dem das von der Helikopter oder der Brug ausgelöst werden wird.
Aber immer ohne die Gleichschirmdrahe.
Also es spricht, dass es Gewicht ist, aber du hast keine Taben ausgelöst.
Das ist jetzt nicht.
In der Realität haben wir meistens die Gleichschirmdrahe nach uns verbunden.
Die Gleichschirm kann auch ein bisschen stören.
Das heisst, das ganze System, das vielleicht eher etwas schaukeln.
Und beeinflusst diesen Zinkenschwindigkeiten definitiv, und das kann auch schnell etwas höher sein.
Allerdings ist es wirklich so, dass, wenn man auf 4 kommt,
dass es eigentlich ein Impact ist, wo man gut an sich kraft.
Am allerwichtigsten einfach, dass man wirklich auf Beih kommt
und nicht gefühlt hat, mit du irgendwie Absitzen.
Und auf der Protektor von einem Gurt zu kommen.
Der Protektor ist nie so gut, wie bei uns.
Es gibt kein Besserbedeck, dass ich bei drum absolut die Priorität nach einem Räter
auf Beih lande.
Wenn wir schon bei den Protektoren sind, da gibt es ganz verschiedene Gurtzüge,
die Protektoren haben.
Und auf der linke Seite haben wir jetzt so ein Schumstoffen gebaut.
Das hat natürlich den Vorteil, der Schutz ist von Anfang an da,
hat einfach den großen Nachtheißes relativ schwer.
Und vor allem, wenn man sie packen, ist recht groß.
Da gibt es andere Formen, um zu zeigen,
wir wollen das Volumen, wenn ich fliehe.
Und hat dann so Erbecks gemacht,
die sich allerdings erst füllen, wenn man in den Luft sind,
wenn der Fahrt in den bloßen muss.
Am Start, wo es sehr wichtig ist, haben wir keinen Schutz.
Da gibt es auch...
Da gibt es auch unten Formen,
die z.B. ein
ein Gurtzüge direkt zum Rucksackerschmacher.
Das sind wir den Wendegurtzüge.
Das Wendegurtz der Vorder, dass kein extra Rucksack brauche,
als Gewichtsersparnis.
Aber wir brauchen jetzt mal die Jahre in den Fest- beasch.
Und mit der Riesverschlüsse, auch sehr viel auf dem Zuhör,
das heisst, es gibt eher mal einen Schaden.
Und der Protekt wird vielleicht so einpackt,
dass er relativ komprimiert drin ist
und entlüfte sich nachher empfaltet sich nicht so schön
nach mehrmaliger Gebrauch.
So, um das Ganze zu lösen,
hat ein Hersteller sehr gut System entwickelt,
wo wir hier im rechten Bild sehen,
wo ein Gurtzüge entwickeln,
wo wir aufblosen durch die Bereitsform starten,
also handisch oder mit so einem Blossack,
damit die Luft innen ist,
wir machen zu und haben bereits ab dem Start
ein super Protekt.
Und wenn man nicht braucht,
dann braucht man die Luftablomie ganz grins,
die Lumen und ganz wenig Gewicht dabei.
Es gibt auch die Extreme-Form,
die Leute wählen, zum Beispiel Heikensleihen,
die sagen, sie verzichten komplett auf den Schutz,
das können wir im linken Ecken haben,
wo den Wücke nur ein Beißig ist,
also ein Gurt, das man bequem drin hat,
dann hat kein Schutz.
Und wir müssen den Notschirm auch separat aufhängen,
nicht integriert im Gurtzüge innen.
In anderen Formen sind die Liga Gurtzüge,
gibt es auch mittlerweile einen Reisemarkt,
die verliert bei Schwer,
schlussendlich die grossen Vorteile
vom Liga Gurtzüge sind ganz klar,
dass man durch eher dynamische Luft liegt,
das ist eine bessere Verkleidleistung vom Schirm.
Und man ist relativ fest windgeschützt,
hat auch so warm, wenn man lange Flüge macht,
und hat relativ viel Platz für ein Cockpit mitgesehen.
Das ist sogar so ein leichtes Schibeligvortrag,
wo man durch ein Gerät optimal platzieren
und gute Sicht auf die Gerät.
Alle, die so ein wenig Wettkampf flügt
oder ein langes Treckerflüge machen,
mehrere Stunden Luft sind,
die jeweil ein eigenes Liga Gurtzüge ist,
die sehr tief für diese Vorteile hat.
Nachdauer sind halt, dass man immer eine frier Umwege ist,
wenn man nicht ganz aufrecht hat.
Das ist völlig ein anderes Gefühl.
Wir müssen sich auch lernen.
Und wir haben nicht die Direktblieck nach oben,
darum, in der Schule macht es absolut Sinn,
einen Sitzgurtzüge zu wählen.
Und dann geht es wie eine klare Schiedene Klasse,
da gibt es Heikoblei Gurtzüge,
da gibt es Steckengurtzüge,
Dachrobatik-Peloten, Freestyle-Peloten,
dann wieder ein anderes Gurtzüge.
Jetzt ganz verschiedene und gute Gurtzüge vom Markt.
Löhnt auch dort, ich beruhte,
das Lohn zu innen zu setzen
und so aus den Finden,
weil es Gurtzüge für euch passt.
Der Aufbau von Leitschirm
haben wir schlussendlich
so ganz einfach dargestellt.
Es geht darum, dass wir einen Drago haben.
Da sehen wir auch hier,
wo wir schlussend aufkankt sind.
Dann Tandschlaufen,
die schlussendlich drin sind,
da haben wir eine kleine A-Märkung,
wenn wir Tandschlaufen haben,
haben sie so,
dann sie so einmal wickeln,
aber nicht so durchführen und fliegen so.
Denn wenn es so in der Handschlaufe drin wäre,
und ich müsste den Noltschirm ziehen,
gerade speziell im Winter,
wenn wir noch Handschen haben,
dass wir uns wie ein Festler nicht auskennen.
Darum eigentlich eine Technik,
wo jederzeit Tandsüber auszubringen.
Dann haben wir kleine,
nämlich Bräumsleinemagans hin,
oder aus der Kanten vom Schirm angemacht ist.
Und nachher geht es ZB und A-Ebenie.
A-Ebenie ist die Vortestelle
oder E-Trittkanten,
die die Luft ist drümmt.
Und dann haben wir es über den Untersegel.
Und im Gleichschirm,
haben wir auch noch ganz viele Innenleben,
da haben wir Zellen zwischend,
und wir haben die sogenannte Crosspots.
Die Crosspots sind nichts anderes als Löcher.
Die Zellenwände, die verursachen,
sind die Luft sich gleichmässig am Flügel auf die Teile.
Wie wir einen Gleichschirm schon mal gesehen haben,
haben wir einen vornen Öffnigen,
und gegen den Außen, gegen den Stabilen,
den Rand zum Gleichschirm,
sind die Öffnigen aufmals zu.
Und das hat die Luft dort in den Kanten,
einen super Stahldruck verursacht.
Dass der Flügel super schön in den Luft liegt.
Und offen ist,
machen wir die Crosspots,
dann finden wir den Luft
Der Trager selber,
haben wir vorgesehen,
das sind die kleinen Ebene,
wir haben die kleinen Schlösschen,
die so kleine Schruppkarabiner sind,
und wir haben den Beschleuniger.
Hier sehen wir jetzt ein Fussbeschleuniger,
die wir mit dem Fuss,
als die erste und einhängt,
mit dem Gurt zu verbinden,
und dem mit dem Fuss kann drücken.
Was ihr nicht anders als hier,
da Ebene oben abzogen wird,
das, was passiert,
der Arsch der Winkel wird klingert,
ist hier mit schneller.
Der Fussbeschleuniger,
wie wir hier auf dem Bild gsennt,
da wir v.a. bei der Soloschein verbaut,
weil dort Piloten können wunderbar
mit dem Beistrecke und Endlasten
die Geschwindigkeit zu beiflosen,
für den Schirm,
was weniger gut geht.
Das ist beim Tandemschirm,
mit Tandemschirm,
haben wir die Trimmens drauf,
wenn man hier gsennta,
wo man hin und aufgelogen kann,
wie wir besprochen,
und das kann man natürlich wunderbar
von Hand machen,
und braucht den Fuss nicht,
weil dort vorne ist,
oder bassen schirmlich,
gar kein Platz.
Der Vorteil der Trimmer,
ist natürlich,
wenn man von Hand ist,
kann man hier auch sehr schön dazu sehen.
Danach der Liste kann es nicht einfach so schnell wieder lösen.
Da muss man aktiv mit der Hand aufgerufen.
Beim Fussbeschleuniger kann man drücken
und loslocken.
Es ist einfach zu bedienen.
Trimmer, Trimming,
nicht zu verwechseln,
da werden wir dann von der Leine,
wo man drüben kann.
Jetzt haben wir folgen,
bei der Leine-Materialie gehört,
dass man da verschiedene Reine haben,
ein bisschen schrumpfen,
bei die Liteinend.
Und der Hersteller versucht,
dass möglichst verhindern,
dass wir einen guten Mix macht
von der jeweiligen Leine.
en.
Es gibt es trotzdem,
dass die Leine sich verformet,
respektive für verlängnere oder klipperkürzend,
und dass du mit dem Check nur messen.
Und jetzt stellt man fest,
dass die Leine doch tatsächlich
verlängt sind,
dann kann man z.B. ein Schlauffinemachen
und so 1, 2, 1,
6, 6, 5, 6, 7, 8,
6, 10, 11, 11, 11, 10, 11,
11, 11, 8, 12, 11,
Die Landen sind schön verpacken in die Artenstelle, damit sie möglichst wenig Sonnen draufschient und so auf die Aufwache stunden
möglichst intensiert werden und nur in der Luft dann ausgesetzt ist.
Nächste ist allgemeines Thema.
Einerseits bei der Leinen ist es nicht gut, weil es schrumpfen, wenn es fest nass sind,
freu am Filn nass sind.
Und das Schirm ist nass nicht das Problem, wenn man auch sofort dreckend spricht.
Schlimm ist, wenn ein Kleidschirm nass ist und nachher durch einen Backsack innen
und der Backsack langst du zwei, drei Wochen im A, dann ist das, wie das Material sicher nicht das Beste.
Umbedingst für mieten, wenn ein nasses Schirm haben, dann dröchnern, die heil ausbreiten
und das ist in der rochenden Zustand wieder verpacken.
Am alles Schlimm, was man machen kann, ist, wenn man nasses Schirm haben und dann noch in Temperaturen aussetzen.
Mit Temperaturen ist das klassische Beispiel im Auto, im Sommer, mit schnell über 30, 40 Grad im Auto.
Und dann haben wir den kleinen Backhofen und das Ganze wirklich im Material sehr schlecht.
Also, schauen, wie es Material trocken ist und dass es nicht in die extremen Temperaturen ausgesetzt ist.
Süre ist etwas, fich dann noch einmal das Landenblatt zu unier aufklassen, dann haben wir einen K coolen Fladen.
Das sind auch etwas, was der Schirm in der Respektive bei der Beschichtung angreift.
Was aber auch wichtig ist, dass man das Zwei putzen muss, mit Wasserlau warm ist, aber nicht irgendwie mit Reinigungsmitteln.
Weil das Ganze durch die Beschichtung angreifen.
Und gerade, wenn man bei der Beschichtung sind, ist es gut stichwort.
Der Gleichschirm hat ja die Beschichtung darauf, dass er eben möglichst nicht die Zwei-Strahle reagiert und dass er vor allem auch
nichts fest luft durch die Parosität, wie wenn ein Schirm zu fest luft durch die Durch-Lod-Verlütel-Leistung,
Verlüt-Kriegung und dann will man verhindern mit dieser Beschichtung, dass das passiert.
Die Beschichtung, die Rips-Stopmasse, die ist natürlich auch unterschiedlich dick, weil die Fälle unterschiedlich dick ist.
Und die Beschichtung wird wieder draufpacken und darauf wird eigentlich besorgt, dass die
Unterschiede von der dicklichen Fälle ausgleichen werden, dass eine Gleichmässungsdurchwerte, dass es auf Abbeständung wird,
dass die Luft durchlässig gut ist und allgemein auf man kann, ist überlastlich weniger schnell reagiert.
Ich hoffe, der Vortrag-Material-Kund hat ich gefallen, ich wiederbringt im Lernen und dass er das Fach-Material-Kult spielt und einfach an der Briefung bestellt.